guy remember all too well and in quite
Vivid Technicolor what it's like to live
in the prison of Shame and guilt and the
fear of confronting that uncomfortable
truth and secret that that lived within
side myself until I was in so much pain
that I really was deprived of any other
choices and was kind of compelled to
confront it that has resulted in not
only healing beyond anything I could
have imagined but also in helping create
a foundation for wholeness so that I
could be in happy successful
relationships there is help and there is
hope and it begins with raising your
hand asking for help and it doesn't have
to be a dramatic gesture it can be a
quiet private gesture but I encourage
you to take that first step because that
first step could lead you on a fantastic
Adventure beyond anything you could
imagine